the Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences
has decided to award the 2017 Nobel
Prize in Physics with one half to Reiner
wise and the other half jointly to bury
C bearish and keep as thorn all of them
members of the LIGO Virgo collaboration
and Academy citation runs for decisive
contributions to the LIGO detector and
the observation of gravitational waves
if you can chide in the by track at some
LIGO detector want a bio bottom from
gravitas Jones Vela put the contribution
decisive or detector illegal he was
observation his own gravitational the
ratio Shave Club Velichko detector is an
AB yudenich gravitational vol and here
as you see we have our new Nobel
laureates with us on the screen above me
a little bit of information about Ryan
advice was born in 1932 in Berlin in
Germany he received his PhD at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology in
the United States and he is still
affiliated with the MIT as professor of
physics dr. Weiss is since many years
the US citizen very bearish was born in
1936 in Nebraska in the United States
his professor of physics at Caltech the
California Institute of Technology
and finally keep Thorne was born in 1940
in Utah in the US and he's currently
professor of theoretical physics at
Caltech and as I mentioned all three
Nobel laureates are members of the LIGO
Virgo collaboration a large team of more
than a thousand scientists who built and
ran the detector that was used to
discover gravitation waves and with that
I'll give the word to the chairman of
the Nobel Committee Niels mortars on who
will give us a brief summary of the
research field
the discovery that has been awarded
today on the 14th of September 2015 the
laser interferometer gravitational-wave
Observatory LIGO succeeded for the first
time to directly observe gravitational
waves these waves were predicted by
Einstein hundred years ago but until now
what they have escaped direct detection
this is a truly remarkable achievement
which crowns almost 50 years of
experimental efforts by hundreds of
scientists and engineers and today the
LIGO collaboration includes a thousand
members from 19 institutions in five
continents who with directly or
indirectly contributed to this
breakthrough this year's Nobel laureates
represent in an excellent way the
diverse competencies needed for like a
success
Rhyno vice laid the foundation for the
detector design he analyzed what
performances had to be reached for the
critical parts of the instrument and
what sources of background noise had to
be mastered and keep someone also
co-founder of LIGO made predictions
about what signals were expected from
different Astrophysical events of
critical importance for the design
beriberi is a scientific leader who
scaled the project up in a stepwise
fashion up to the advanced LIGO thereby
reaching the sensitivity which will in
the end allow the successful detection
without them this guy the discovery
would not have happened
we now witness the dawn of a new field
gravitational wave astronomy this will
teach us about the most violent
processes in the universe and it will
lead to new insights into the nature of
extreme gravity and now Olga botner will
give us some more insights into the
discovery the scientists and the
collaboration oh God the floor is yours
thank you
I've try not to stand in the way of
anyone once upon a time a long time ago
in a galaxy far far away two massive
black holes engaging in a deadly dance
revolving around each other
spiraling fast and fast the whirling
finally at half the velocity of light
they collided and merged forming an even
more massive black hole this momentous
event reverberates through space and
time as gravitational waves spread
outwards carrying information on what
had just happened these events took
place about 1.3 billion years ago at a
time when the first multicellular life
emerged on earth ever since then have
the gravitational waves sped through the
universe reaching our cosmic
neighborhood the Magellanic Clouds about
200,000 years ago when early homo
sapiens
walked in Africa and finally swept
through the earth on September 14 2015
when the ways were recorded by perhaps
the most sensitive instrument ever
devised by man the LIGO interferometer
gravitational-wave Observatory at 950 45
UTC this event caused a sensation
worldwide
we knew that gravitational waves existed
indirectly but this was the first time
ever they had been directly observed and
this of course made the headlines of
major newspapers like the New York Times
so what are the gravitational waves well
they were predicted by Einstein within
his general theory of relativity
gravitational waves arise when heavy
bodies accelerate that is when the
velocity is changing with time they are
disturbances of space-time traveling
through the universe at the speed of
light causing space to alternately
stretch and shrink at right angles to
the direction of motion now the effect
the gravitational strain is tiny even
from a ponderous event like the
collision and merger of two black holes
if we imagine a ruler the length of the
earth diameter like thirteen thousand
kilometers a passing gravitational wave
would make this ruler vibrate by one
trillionth of a millimeter which is
about the size of an atomic nucleus
nevertheless the team of scientists led
by this year's Nobel laureate succeeded
in measuring this tiny vibrance the key
to the success is laser interferometry
and I'm now trying to explain the
principle behind laser interferometry
for you the light from a laser is led
towards a beam splitter where the light
is split along two detector arms at
right angle to each other in the case of
legatees detector arms are four
kilometer long mirrors at the end of the
arms reflect the light back which was
the beam splitter where the two waves
are overlaid and channeled towards a lie
detector where fringe pattern is
registered now a passing gravitational
wave will make one of the arms shrink
when the other arm expands and this
makes the pattern shift very very
slightly and this is what the scientists
detect now the effect is incredibly
small and the detect
is amazingly sensitive a passing truck
or ocean waves beating against the far
shore caused a disturbance which must be
monitored and offset also to exclude
local disturbances each like a detector
cannot operate on its own and this is
why the light observatory comprises two
detectors one in Hanford in Washington
State and the other in Livingston
Louisiana on opposite coasts of the
American continent separated by about
3000 kilometers and on the left hand
you see panels showing you the
gravitational wave registered on
September 14 2015 by the two detectors
the upper panel shows the wave
registered at Hanford the middle panel
at Livingston and the bottom panel shows
the two waveforms overlaid shifted by
the time difference between the
gravitational waves arrival at the two
sides which was six point nine
milliseconds and what I would like you
to note in the bottom panel is how
identical the two waveforms are and this
is essential to be able to recognize
this event as a true occurrence and not
the phone signal now looking at this
lower hand at the left-hand panel I
would like you to know something else
namely that the waveforms wiggle fast
and faster as time progresses to reach a
climax at about 0.4 seconds this is the
point where the black holes merge and
then to quiet down now this increase in
frequency with time can be represented
in terms of an audible signal and I'm
going to play for you this audible
signal the now so famous chirp of the
gravitational wave
but to do that you have to be very quiet
and listen for a faint wine which is
when the two black holes merge I'm going
to play this four times so here goes and
this brings me to my last slide the
discovery the first ever observation of
a gravitational wave was a milestone
opening a new window to the universe the
prospects of observing black holes hands
on a tremendously exciting as are the
prospects of being able to see the dark
parts of the universe the parts of the
universe from which electromagnetic
radiation light does not reach us since
the first observation three more
discoveries of gravitational waves
passing the earth have been made the
last one announced less than a week ago
where the twin LIGO detectors operated
in concert with a sister detective Virgo
in Italy this is truly the dawn of
gravitational wave astronomy and I
couldn't help but end with Einstein who
obviously was right again even though
back when for a while he didn't believe
that gravitational waves existed and so
I'm going to leave you with the picture
of the three Nobel laureates the leaders
of the international team of scientists
behind the discovery that shook the
world thank you thank you very much Olga
for that exciting introduction to the
field we may now have one of our Nobel
laureates with us on a phone line from
the US dr. Weiss are you there
oh I'm here yes yes absolutely good
morning this is Johanna Martin the guy
who woke you up
yes okay now we go or so how are you no
I'm fine I even have clothing on very
good it's just a phone line so so it's
not but you don't have to freeze them so
I'm not sitting in the beautiful session
hall of the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences we're in the midst of the press
conference here are journalists from
Swedish and international media and I'm
sure they would like to ask you some
questions
so are you ready for them dr. Weiss I
hope I am I hope I can understand yeah
please too much Pineda good morning
professor congratulations Swedish
television four point is my name I'm
curious we just heard that now by sort
of seeing these gravitational waves you
can deduce what happened when two black
holes merged and what else is there that
we can learn now that we can detect them
well there's a huge amount of things to
find out in the universe that radiate
gravitation plates mean the black holes
who are the Bobby the strongest sort but
there are many many others for example
the neutron stars themselves which are
now stars that are not yet back home
they're stars that are quite fine - Todd
is and they get together in fact very
fruit discovery that was made of
habitation a direct discovery but a very
important one was done with a pair of
neutron stars there was a Nobel Prize
gift
back in the 90s where they were observed
neutron stars their fear kept going
around each other and through the
motions you could determine the motions
of the two stars you could determine
that they were radiating gravitation it
was a pager to stop in the field of
habitation the other kinds of things
that that was a we hope be those we hope
the in fact the supernova one point it's
not so easy absolutely any of them but
these are stars that have come to the
end of their lives and they then rapidly
collapse and in the process of
collapsing if they have any kind of a
spherical most kinetic completely
spherical which most likely will be the
case they will also radiate and in fact
they will radiate that tell us really Oh
Donnie the super node which yeah the
[Music]
eventually the idea King for a
background creation of gravitational
waves is a just annoyed that comes from
the whole universe in a way because you
have quite resolved all the sources but
there will be a background north of
gravitational wave so there is now a way
of looking techniques that which the
power part of the universe never police
thought of think that if not then their
messages out like they sent them out I
make so comes with part of astronomy and
ask not just the uniqueness of have paid
a technophobe or a cue of part of the
science under you know okay thank you
very much
there is slight problem with the phone
line but I think you could here we have
a question over there yeah
congratulations professor Weiss I'm
sufficient access own freelance reporter
for Channel Radio and
also reporter photo in post my question
is did you expect this or did you know
that you have been nominated and what
what was your reaction my you heard a
news thank you
I mean I but I do I view this before as
they they think that is recognized the
support of about a thousand feet and
it's the work Vidya dedicated effort has
been going on or I hate to tell you it's
as long as forty years of people
thinking about this trying to make a
detection of sometimes failing in the
early days and then slowly but surely
getting the technology together to be
able to do it and it's very very
exciting that it worked out in the end
that we are actually detecting and
actually adding to the knowledge through
gravitational waves the what goes on in
the youth is a wonderful experience sort
of begun anew and I many of us were in
this fully expect that we'll learn
things that we didn't know about I mean
at this moment we do know about we knew
about black holes other ways and we knew
about neutron stars we've known about
well those are the two things that
ultimately are seen but the thing is
that we hope that there are all of the
phenomena that you can see mostly
because of the gravitational waves they
admit that will open a new science and
will add to the science that has already
you know such a deep thing in terms of
understanding the unit so I can't ask
you any better than I think that was a
great answer thank you very much more
questions the lady over there hi I'm
anali magnet horn and I'm from the
Swedish TV for congratulations this was
a really cool discovery I wonder when I
know when them jammed damn got the first
Nobel Prize in Physics when he
discovered the x-ray I don't think he
thought that in a hundred or a little
bit more time we will be using these
x-ray waves in hospitals daily and
dentists and so on and I wonder in a
hundred years from now do you think we
will have little small devices and
measured those gravitational waves
what if you can speculate in a hundred
years what do you think your discovery
will be used for yeah that's an
interesting question I have what much
about the when we think about the future
for this view you think of proving that
so that we can look deeper and deeper if
the and in particular at some point but
not the detectors have now because
they're not they're not they're not hope
to be able to look at the beginnings of
the universe for example we hope at some
point to have detectors that are
sensitive enough so that you spot black
holes over the entire unit so that you
can see the evolution of that particular
time sort and as time goes on we hope to
detect get more if I don't think they'll
get necessary oh yeah that's my guess
they will probably get more and more
sense this before Apollo would learn how
to make the detector as easily another
fact it's any of these vectors and in
the process match-ups
think like very the very earliest moment
in the ether person one of the ideas
thought about all right but Texas for
example there are calculations that
indicate that the very earliest the
universe brighter there is an enormous
amount back to it generated that would
be a better that be fried right now
but by radio
and looking at the effect that occur
later on in the universe has driven by
the earliest preparation wait
I hope those but they are made yet we
need do this very directed put the grab
your babes directly that come from that
earliest F that would be a one of the
most fascinating thing man could because
it'll tell you very much how the
universe start the fascinating idea and
gravitation fades since they are so
super turbo they go through everything
they will tell you most information it
yet about the earliest go on a
universally hope so
I think it's a wonderful feel and I hope
it's which man until be really get
everything to the point but is that we
can do cosmological a lot investing
reputation okay we're running a bit
short of time I think there is time for
one short question one short answer
please yeah
good morning professor vice my name is
Eric and I came I'm working at the
Swedish national news agency tt
congratulations at first I really I
would like to know what you felt like
when you heard the gravitational wave
for the first time
well what when we first went first
discovered them yeah back in in the back
in September of nineteen rather many of
us didn't believe it tell you that have
a program where we inject signals the
best the detector that's what we thought
it was it took us a long time or
something like two months to really
admit to ourselves that we've had seen a
thing that came from the outside and was
tria gravitated with if it was not
truthful
convinced oneself that one had seen
those and then as time has now gone on
seen more of these events similar kinds
of events from blackballed and it makes
it far more likely and I now very much
convinced I don't think there's anybody
left Dallas that affected these
gravitational waves
okay thank you very much professor vice
for being with us at this press
conference and we're looking forward to
welcoming you to Stockholm in December
thank you very much thank you bye bye
bye and now are there any questions for
the panel or dr. Butler and dr. Weiss
explained it all to you okay
in that case if there are no further
questions we'll close this session and I
know that several of you have requested
individual interviews that will commence
so thank you very much
thank you
yesterday
[Music]
discovery the world
well what happened to black holes
collided a long long time ago and the
amazing thing is that no humans existed
when black holes collided
but while the ways travel through the
universe Homo sapiens developed on earth
and by the time the waves reach the
earth we know not only existed but had
developed instruments which was
sufficiently sensitive to detect this
tiny tiny vibration of earth when the
gravitational waves where the past where
was the collision well the collision was
four hundred mega parsec away we don't
know which galaxy it was exactly but we
know that it was 1.3 billion light-years
away which is quite far away but it's
very difficult to pinpoint the location
exactly because the detectors we have
are not very sensitive directional so
they can point to an arc on the sky we
might have happened but cannot say
exactly that this was where
it might happen closer to us in in the
near future but we are getting so few
gravitation away and this at this time
but I cannot tell you when we'll see
something which is even closer dangerous
for us this will probably not be
dangerous for us unless earth would
collide with a black hole which which is
not going to happen anytime soon but the
effect is so tremendously small and here
we're talking about trillions of a
millimeter on a length which is the size
of the diameter of the earth but this is
not something which an ordinary human
which would even feel this is why we
need is extremely sensitive instrument
so even when they arrived at Earth
nobody could just feel it just true us
so we believe that there are
gravitational waves sweeping through the
earth all the time now now if we're
lucky and the amplitude is slightly
larger then we are able to detect them
but mostly we are not even able to see
them what was this sound of the
gravitational wave like
also the point is and I want to stress
that that gravitational waves are not
sound but the waveform has Wiggles in
them and if you look at these Wiggles
and how they vary over time you can
represent what you see in terms of an
audible signal and this was the chair of
review just so it so happens the
frequency of this waveforms is almost
the range of human hearing and this is
by wrist
we're saying that the gravitational
waves are loud that we can deliver so
what was the main achievement of this
year's Lawrence competencies are quite
complimentary rhino vise is the founder
of the whole project he developed the
concept starting in the beginning or the
middle of the 1960's he built the first
prototype detectors in 1967 and then he
demonstrated the principle he charted
the various noise sources which would
influence the performance of the
detector and as I I've been trying to
mention the detect is incredibly
sensitive a truck passing by will make a
detector vibrate ocean waves some
distance away make also the detector
vibrate say small lodging other things
so you have to know very very well what
kind of sources can give you signals
which simulates gravitational wave to be
able to distinguish the true from the
false so his main influence on the
project is
developing a prototype chartering all
the sources of disturbances and finding
means to offset these sources thorn is
this inspiring theorist who figured out
what kind of signals you can expect from
Astrophysical sources of these waves so
what to look for how sensitive does the
instrument have to be to be able to
observe what the universe behaves like
in terms of gravitational waves and then
we have very bearish who is the person
who joined the experimental lie even he
only arrived from the scene in 1994
however he is the visionary behind
upgrading the sensitivity of the
instrument to the level when this
detection was possible the original
layer could not have made the detection
which was possible thanks to the
development initiated by very bearish
worked like for 50 years with this
project well what did they say when they
got the call from Sepang this morning
well I think expecting it as I said at
the press conference the first discovery
of a gravitational wave the first direct
measurement caused a sensation worldwide
so it's been speculated already for a
year that this was a deserving discovery
and so I think they were half expecting
they were still humble and very very
gratified that they were awarded the
prize but also all three of them
mentioned one that they were happy that
they were not alone and two that we
should make sure to stress the role of
the collaboration at the press
conference and I'm gonna be awards how
was this collaboration the lack of
collaboration yes the light of
collaboration has grown over the last
fourteen years in the beginning it was
small it was just groups at MIT and at
Cal Tech at the universities in the
United States but then as the detector
grew in size and people started talking
of kilometer long arms
the collaboration also proved and groups
joined all across the United States but
also in Europe and in Australia
so today the LIGO collaboration consists
of scientists at 90 universities all
across the world so you are like going
to invite to stock on my thousand
scientists unfortunately I don't think
it is possible but each Nobel laureate
has the opportunity of inviting a
certain number of peoples I hope that
we'll get on representatives from across
the collaboration so no word when the
gravitational waves are here in some
sense what will they tell us about the
universe so what we hope to learn from
the gravitational waves is
one about black hole and about gravity
in a strong regime you have to imagine
gravity as the weakest force who know of
it's much weaker than electromagnetism
just think of a kitchen magnet a small
magnet you put on the door of your
fridge it stays up it doesn't fall to
the ground it just shows you that the
electromagnet is was much stronger than
gravity so the gravity forces we know of
from the a weak gravitational forces
close to black holes the extremely
strong so the discovery of gravitational
waves carrying information from the
surroundings of black holes will teach
us something about this strong regime of
gravity which is very very exciting
we'll learn something about violent
explosions like supernovae or gamma-ray
bursts
we might learn something about the Big
Bang because the Big Bang left imprint
on the universe in terms of
gravitational waves which we've never
seen before they are even weaker than
those which have been observed
previously but even more exciting the
parts of the universe which are dark
which you've never seen before because
electromagnetic radiation doesn't reach
us from there gravitational waves are
unstoppable so they will so we hope to
learn about this dark
you